Bernie Sanders America's favorite
socialist
has a new event
for his new book
the event in the book are called it's
okay to be angry about capitalism
and if you want to go to the event about
the book about how it's okay to be angry
about capitalism you can do that
for the low low price of 95 dollars
Bernie so he's got cheap tickets too
he's got the 35 tickets but the tickets
go up to 95 dollars this will be hosted
on March first in Washington DC
the book is available from penguin
random house it's 28 dollars it's pretty
expensive for a book wouldn't you say
and penguin writes quote
reflecting on our turbulent times
Senator Sanders takes on the billionaire
class and speaks blunt truths about our
country's failure to address the
destructive nature of a system that is
fueled by uncontrolled greed and rigidly
committed to prioritizing corporate
profits over the needs of ordinary
Americans notice Bernie is no longer
talking about the millionaire class
he used to for most of his political
career he would invade against the
Millionaires and the billionaires and
then
a few years ago he dropped the
millionaires part
now he only invades against the
billionaires the billionaire class and
the reason for that is
Bernie became a millionaire
and so the moment that Bernie became a
millionaire and then the millionaires
were okay now now it's just the
billionaires pretty much the only bad
people are the people with one dollar
more than Bernie Sanders has
and he's about to get a lot dollars more
many many more dollars than he
previously had because he's going to
sell this book and he's going to sell
tickets to his event now
Bernie does have a slight point he
doesn't know that he has a point but he
does have a slight point
most conservatives looking at this at
least most conservative pundits and
politicians looking at this they're
going to say how dare you Bernie
capitalism is the greatest thing ever
there's nothing wrong with capitalism
we're all Ardent capitalists capitalism
is the greatest thing in since life
spread
the thesis that Bernie is advancing here
it's okay to be angry about capitalism
he's got a little bit of a point
I don't know when conservatives became
the capitalists we became the promoters
of capitalism or really almost any ISM
whatsoever I'm skeptical of pretty much
all isms and let's not forget capitalism
is a word that was popularized by Karl
Marx okay
what does it mean what is capitalism
there are plenty of problems with
capitalism
if by capitalism we mean
the modern system of Industry the way
that the economy were there are problems
with the way the economy works
now Bernie thinks there's problems with
the way the economy works because he
wants to steal all the money from
anybody who's richer than him and he
wants to flatten out society and he
wants the workers of the world to unite
in a proletarian Communist Revolution
right that's all wrong but I've got
problems with the way the economy works
I think the way the economy works right
now is rigged against against many good
Americans I think that it can be
terribly destructive to traditional
culture
I think that it is often being wielded
by political Elites who are simply
trying to enrich themselves and grow
their own power
and pursue their own bizarre utopian
Vision rather than actually support the
common good of the United States there's
that's that's plenty true that is plenty
true I think about the the William Blake
poem
Jerusalem where he's which then became a
hymn where he he asks and did those feet
in ancient time walk upon England's
mountains green he's talking about this
Legend the Joseph of Arimathea took
Jesus to England
and he's saying it was the Holy Lamb of
God on England's Pleasant pastures seen
and and then he he you think why is
William Blake talking about this this
wild Legend of Christ in England
and then then he gets to the point in
the second stanza of the poem where he
says
what was was
Jesus actually here in this land
which which we now find ourselves among
these dark satanic Mills that's the
phrase the dark satanic Mills what is
Blake talking about he's talking about
industrialization there are plenty of
dark things about industrialization our
modern industrial society has broken
down the family broken down communities
it's turned us all into Mass consumers
it's made us all very materialistic it's
it's degraded mankind into a kind of
widgets for an assembly line rather than
full integrated human beings
yeah those are real problems
those are totally real problems
I don't think the solution is is
Bernie's Communist Revolution but we can
work on that there are right-wing
critiques of modern capitalism
after all it's a term promoted by Marx
so we don't we don't need to throw the
cultural Improvement out with the Bernie
bath water but we also shouldn't give
him 95 to read a stupid book illegal
immigration
is not working out so great for a
sanctuary City you know New York said
we're a sanctuary City please come here
surge give us your poor huddled masses
and then the moment that Greg Abbott and
Texas and Rhonda Sanders in Florida
actually ship some immigrants up there
all of a sudden they say well well we're
getting too many immigrants cut that out
why are you sending immigrants up here
that's no good and so New York has put
them up in some hotel rooms the the
illegal aliens don't want to leave those
nice hotel rooms now the New Yorkers are
sick of footing the bill for this even
the mayor is starting to pull his hair
out
what is the reality of illegal
immigration what the libs tell us is
illegal immigration is
poor women and widows and orphans and
little doe-eyed dreamers they're just
yearning to be free walking across the
border how dare you turn them away
the reality of what we're seeing in New
York a little bit different
Hotel
um actually is the entire hotel from the
third floor to the 28th floor and what
what are you witnessing what did you see
from the migrants that were staying in
your hotel
chaos total chaos I mean there's no
accountability the city is so-called
running the program
um allows these people to destroy these
rooms there is no uh daily supervision
to show these people that this is a
hotel and that you don't destroy the
hotel you're only there temporarily this
is not your home
um unfortunately uh the ones that are
paying the prize is the hotel workers uh
local sex union workers those guys and
those ladies
um endure a lot of disrespect from the
migrants and there is some nice migrants
but there's too much alcohol too much
drugs and too much violence and you have
teenagers you know going into the
staircases and making out and like it's
love is Lane I mean you know this is a
free fall for all
a little bit different than what we're
told by the libs and this is a guy who
is a worker at one of these hotels I
suspect this this man is not racist
against the illegal immigrants this is
not about racism or
anti-hispanic bigotry he's just seeing
what he's seen and he's saying man we
got to stop this this is bad this whole
hotel is full of these migrants
mostly if you look at the cameras it's
mostly young men
because
the uh contrary to what we've been told
most of these migrants are not fleeing
political persecution most of these
migrants are not full family units just
seeking a better life it's young men
seeking Economic Opportunity
and they're not behaving in a way that
is particularly respectful of their host
country obviously not their very first
Act
As would-be Americans is to break one of
our most basic laws
not very respectful so the fact that
they're trashing this hotel in New York
not surprising to me at all that's the
reality of it it's very very expensive
for the people of New York the rest of
the show continues now we've got a story
that I haven't gotten to uh we will get
to that and we will get to all of your
comments so become a member right now
dailywire.com
Knowles k o w l e s use code Knowles at
checkout yet two months free on all
annual plans
[Music]
foreign